I don't know nothing to control me but
me and so I gotta put myself under
extreme discipline to make sure I'm free
because without the ability to influence
and persuade your cats you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are I want to
make some money I can't make I can't
really be successful by myself
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it
and make a difference using it now I
started the belief life series to once a
week tackle a different topic that is
outside just building a business and
helping you be a better you so to help
you live your best believe life today
we're gonna learn the ten skills that
you need to develop if you want to be
rich
enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick things off with skill
number one discipline yourself with Eric
Thomas it's always like yo you got to
discipline yourself I started looking at
mother Teresa of Gandhi and I was like
yo bro Gandhi would go fast from sex and
he was married he would fast from
talking you know I just started watching
these great peoples like these people
fast and not about fast and like that's
not the peace but they were very
discipline people and they would not
allow their exterior world to dominate
or destroy their internal world I just
like you I want to get to a place where
I can control me my family members have
grown a loss too uncle cirrhosis of the
liver brilliant man but just drinking
drinking drinking and I was like yo I do
not want to my father was a substance
abuser for years I was like you know I
don't want a life where something else
is controlling me you know like for real
when I left home and said I don't want
to be controlled no more like I meant
that like I don't know nothing to
control me but me and so I gotta put
myself under extreme discipline to make
sure I'm free so when people see me you
get up at 3:00 you don't drink you don't
smoke I'm not doing that because I think
I'm better no BIOS oh I think you gonna
go to hell because you had a drink I
just want I want to control I want
freedom and for me disciplining myself
means more freedom and unless I you
discipline yourself people who I told my
son other dad's like your son I don't
not want you to have fun I just seen a
history of people who just have fun
Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween know
there are the people learns there not
every night
the other people who end up in their 20s
having a great deal of fun but in a 40s
and 50s they working for somebody and
I'm not saying I'm wrong with cleaning
toilets but they doing something they
don't want to do for the rest of a life
and they can't retire because they
played so much you know so for me I just
look at Venus in Sarina Michael Jackson
when he used to like five and six just
dancing all night I just think the more
man discipline himself the greater don't
mean it's gonna happen but the greater
the probability that he has this sense
of freedom skill number two
you have self-motivation with Mark Cuban
when you find something you're good at
yeah go for it and I also also always
say it's not about passion
everybody's got passion for something
yeah right don't follow your passions
follow your efforts because people say
you know I was passionate to play
baseball I was passionate to play
basketball doesn't mean out all the
sudden I was gonna be good enough yeah
but I found myself spending being really
curious about business being really
curious about technology and that
curiosity is really what drove me and I
think particularly if you're young today
curiosity is great always learning and
trying to find new things being curious
about new things because that's what
leads you to that path trying to figure
out in advance yeah that's hard because
you don't know what you don't know I was
never really into technology when I was
a kid but then as I got a job that used
it I found out I was good at it and once
I found out I was good at it then it
became a lot more fun yeah you know when
you're good at something it's almost
always fun yeah and once it was fun and
I combined that with you know my
business skills then I saw okay I know
how to make money at this stuff because
I know how to sell now I know tech that
gives me something I love to do and so
you know what I oh I tell people the key
is find something you love to do and be
great at it yeah because once you do
that it's all gravy skill number three
maintain focus with Will Smith I
realized that when you to have the level
of success that I want to have it's
difficult to spread it out and do
multiple things you know it's in order
to to be world-class and I've made a
decision I want to be world-class and it
just it takes such a desperate obsessive
focus to to excel on assert honor on the
level that I want to make movies you
know I was a Star Wars when I was young
i sat in the movie theater and watched
Star Wars and I just couldn't believe
that that movie made me feel like that
just floored and just stunned by the
creativity and just I'm realizing that
in order to move people in that way in
order to touch people in that way you've
really got to focus with all of your
fiber and all your heart and all your
creativity skill number four read with
Tai Lopez the fact that people argue
with me on this reading thing and people
argue with me about men
[ __ ] know just use your own gut
feeling is that how you learn English
when you were two years old you use your
gut feeling to start conjugating verbs
no you learn from other people you learn
manners you learn language you learn all
things valuable you learn to drive from
another person so it doesn't make sense
you learn life so books are just the
mentors who maybe are dead now you wanna
learn about Steve Jobs
he ain't alive to teach you but you can
learn through accumulated wisdom and
that's what trust me
I meet I very few powerful businessman
I've ever met
don't read a lot Warren Buffett who I
think's the best businessman by far in
the world because done see has 75
companies that he pretty much runs 200
billion in revenue he reads eight hours
a day
he reads 600 he said he slowed down in
his old age I only reads 500 pages a day
Bill Gates goes on reading vacations
Mark Zuckerberg just start started a
reading once a week book club on
Facebook and I already got a couple
million fathers and now with audiobooks
there's no excuse you got YouTube videos
let this thing run in the background
like you want to become like a
supercomputer you just download smart
crap from smart people and you pick and
choose like some people are like Thai I
don't agree with everything you say I'm
like good I don't agree with everything
I say like a year later I'm like wait I
was wrong
skill number five play the long game
with Jeff Bezos I asked everybody to not
think in two to three year time frames
but to think in five to seven year time
frames to not think about when somebody
says to me congratulate Sam azan on a
good quarter which is a very common
thing to say you meet somebody they're
being nice they looked at your financial
results for the quarters of a good
quarter I say thank you but what I'm
thinking to myself is that quarter all
that those quarterly results were
actually pretty much fully baked about
three years ago and so like today I'm
working on you know
a quarter that is going to happen in
2020 not next quarter next quarter for
all practical purposes is done already
and it's probably been done for a couple
of years and so if you start to think
that way it changes how you spend your
time how you plan where you put your
energy and and your ability look around
corners gets better so many things
improve if you can take a long term by
the way it's not natural for humans so
it's a it's a discipline that you have
to build the the kind of you know get
rich slowly schemes are not big sellers
on infomercials you know it's and so
that's something that you have to sort
of steel yourself for discipline and
teach over time skill number six learn
how to sell with Jordan Belfort Warren
Buffett was doing the speech of Bill
Gates about maybe ten years ago and he
was asked by a college student what can
we do as students to make ourselves more
valuable in the workplace so you think
Warren Buffett would say learn how to
pick stocks learn how investments you
know whatever he would say not what he
says he says go out and take a course in
sales and communication there he did
Dale Carnegie chain says like there you
go now that point because he took that
he said I took Dale Kearney changement
without back you don't he'd be without
that course yeah he'd be the richest
money manager in Omaha Nebraska then no
one ever heard of yeah Annie met his
wife that way the love is like because
without the ability to influence and
persuade your Kanaks you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are skill
number seven learn to outsource with
Kevin O'Leary
great entrepreneurs are able to delegate
the successful women's CEOs are
remarkably good at this remarkably good
at it and the way it works is Sarah give
I'll give you an example the way Sarah
works she hires somebody she sets a goal
for 90 days and gets out of their way
gets completely out of their way lets
them achieve it if they achieve it she
moves them up the organization if they
don't they get three tries until they're
out if you can't achieve your goals in
business that's what happens but her
whole thing is let them do the work
themselves let them figure it out I
want to use my time for it that's what I
hired them for skill number eight make
sacrifices with Emma Stone I was 15 when
I came out to LA to audition so I don't
think I was even you know cooking with
all four burners and it's one of those
things where you're like I'm so lucky to
be doing this that it's not like you can
really complain but I missed going to my
best friend's wedding because of it so
it's like there are those things but I
think we all have that I mean in any job
there are sacrifices in any relationship
they're sacrifices we're all as human
beings dealing with that balancing all
the things that we we want to do and we
dream of doing with our responsibilities
and our relationships and yeah so skill
number 9
know how to lead with Gary Vaynerchuk
you can't you can't you can't what you
can do is you can hustle and then people
will either ride up to it or run away
from it like you know I don't judge my
people first of all nobody that works
for you should hustle as hard as you
period you want somebody to hustle as
hard as you that works for you give them
the same economics you're taking home
that's extreme number two with kids rich
kids aren't gonna care as much as you
about money because you didn't have any
and so you had a fight for it and then
that's just real so I think you said I
set the tone for my company some people
rise up some people find their work-life
balance some people bounce I'm not in
the game of thinking that's important if
I feel good about what I'm paying
somebody for for what I'm getting in
return I don't need to judge that they
need to work harder so I don't want to
get a deal for my people do you
understand I want mighty people to be on
my team not me getting more value out of
them it's a huge mistake of business
owners and skill number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
surround yourself with greatness with
Sean Combs the road to the bag is
definitely tied to your team in the
company that you keep
if you are surrounding yourself with
different energies that's not on the
same wavelength as you if they not
praying for you inspiring you supporting
you for showing you a better way hello
remove them immediately or you could
take them to church pray for taking the
church but you can't help them get there
though you got to take care yourself you
know what it's called it's like we
talked about the other day is like being
on the airplane and the thing come down
you got to take care of yourself first
you know they put the mask on put the
mask off really takes some time and
really look at who you're surrounding
yourself with look who's to the left and
to the right of you ain't like minded
are they disciplined are they pushing
you forward it's so simple for us to
solve this a lot of the hardest problems
are so easy to solve we just have to
take those steps which are hard and be
mindful of that
cuz trust me that energy is gonna affect
you if you're around thousand gangsters
you gonna be in jail if you're around
casters talking negative you gonna be
negative if you're around some brush
you're gonna be rope broke freeze
puffing around some month if you're
around God and some money you on your
way you're on your way you're on your
way I want to make some money I can't
make I can't really be successful by
myself I need other people around me so
you where you are as great as your team
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Patrick Beit David on how to spend
time learning but before getting to that
I want to know from you what's your
commitment of the day you just watch
this video you learned about ten new
skills which one are you going to apply
do you need to apply to your life or to
your business write it down in the
comments below and as you write it down
it's much more likely to actually happen
so let's see what you got in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
I want you to go on your YouTube channel
and forget about if you don't have a
YouTube channel go on the search button
above and click on history and watch the
last 20 videos you have watched on
YouTube and this is what I want you to
do categorize the videos on which ones
of them are educational and which ones
are entertainment if 50% or more of the
videos are entertainment you're not
really fully committed to want it to
become wealthy you're more committed to
become entertained and it's not going to
happen go on YouTube and look the top
1000 videos keep going until you find
the first video that has to do with a
how-to you know how many videos are
ahead hundreds if not thousands because
most of the world doesn't care about
wanting to fully found the secrets about
business and life and entrepreneurship
they want to be entertained this is why
Hollywood make so much money because
they know most of the world it's fully
just committed to an entertainment that
maybe you go look at your search by the
way you can go on your history also on
your Google and look what what's that
you visit and what you do with your time
that you have if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]